[Applaudissements]
tout d'abord la tenue de nuit l'aurait
alors qu'elle a vraiment chez elle de
nadège
[Applaudissements]
alors ça mérite une explication vous
dormez vraiment comme ça comme ça ah ah
je ne pouvais pas venir tout nu mais en
revanche je suis comme ça et le pire
c'est que j'ai des bouchons dans les
oreilles et un masque c est le jour où
il m'a vu comme ça on a mûri il m'a dit
qu'est ce que tu es belle je suis
vraiment amoureux parce que là c'est
vraiment et c'est surtout pour ça que
vous n'avez pas eu pendant longtemps
d'amoureux en ce moment mais voilà vous
ou mais ça se passe bien mais imaginez
quand même que le type voit sa fiancée à
la télé en tenue de nuit entendu faire
mon amour quand vous allez rentrer vous
allez trouver la force armée
c'était neige numéro deux chroniqueurs
commentent hormis de la nuit par christo
carrière
[Applaudissements]
on sait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok c'est pas parce qu'il fait un carton
c'est vraiment le genre de tenues que
vous mettez le soir pour dormir
win a enfin la gemmi le tee shirt de
soirée parce que voilà d'habitude je
mets ce t-shirt là je ne mets pas tout
le temps parce qu'il est pas mais vous
avez raison c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut pas pour le parti chama est
authentique et je précise que tout à
l'heure dans le petit concours de chant
comédie musicale que va arbitrer alex le
gagnant aura ce superbe casque achetable
jeter pmp mais le perdant partira il
choisira la tenue de nuit des
chroniqueurs avec l'odeur on la laisse
tel quel dans le jus bon ben pas mal
hein c'était bien pour vous deux voilà
on les applaudit
allez quand même à venir à la télé vous
montrer tout simple numéro 3
à votre avis sexy pas sexy mairie que la
nuit tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
bonjour je m'attendais je ne vous le
cache pas j'ai un truc un peu plus
affriolants ça ça et confort oui c'est
qu'on force les chaussons maman des
vosges et les chaussons vosgien donc de
laine de mouton je sais pas grand mère
bah voyons
non pas terrible et j'aime bien mais
j'ai préféré que j'ai tout à l'heure
mais attendez d'un miami qui suivront
nous a dit qu'il y avait vu très bien
beau cadeau de voter pour vous ça ah oui
je suis inquiet alors maintenant c'est
peut-être bientôt qu'il va falloir aller
coucher les enfants ont parlé tout à
l'heure de plus belle la vie à côté
c'est du pipi de chat
car voici the boss
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais attendez la belle endormie avec
sapin le soir vous êtes comme ça chez
moi je veux rancune hot
oui mais j'avais quand même pas venir en
culotte et infliger ça aux enfants ont
presque enfants donc j'ai trouvé ça
c'est pas mal et effectivement comme je
dors sur le canapé après avoir vaincu
love me mets un truc dort sur le canapé
pour que vous dormez sur le canapé
quatuor ce cadavre est plus près de la
porte de sortie pour partir le matin
parce que je pars à 3h30 et redémarrer
et vous le laisser seul dans le livre
vous dormez dans le cadre que là je
rejoins le week-end non du lundi au
vendredi vous dormez sur le cam appelé
lundi au vendredi baby gros et dui
ceinture et le samedi matin j'arrive en
culotte bandits parce que si j'arrive
avec ça il met faudrait plus de ne pas
séparer nuits avec anna faire passer par
une nuit avec lui du lundi au vendredi
vous ne passez pas venu avec lui normal
nous est réservé pour le week-end une
heure je me lève à 3 vous croyez pas
qu'en plus ce même cinq minutes dans ces
cas-là dormaient dans la voiture où sera
encore plus près isabelle moret bosque
ces messieurs c'est maintenant relizane
gentleman je peux le faire à las vegas
tu peux je vais te dire ce qu'il faut
annoncer c'est eux qui reviennent las
vegas attention spectacle américain gros
tuyaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette seule cette seule et vous dire
c'est du fellini
mais paul brillaud petit priori pas ce
qu'il a dit tout à l'heure qui quand le
surnommer gros tuyaux mais vous imaginez
que ce type est directeur des magazines
de presse il arrive puis comme ça en se
faisant avec le public qui ont le gros
thuir toronto
[Applaudissements]
alors je voudrais d'ailleurs ce bric à
sion ont dit tous ici à la voyez où il a
l'impression que c'est gros c'est pas
très beau mais en plus il avait une
boîte de mouchoirs le gars je vous
assure que ça la décla l'ex pourrait
nouer bout et ça fait rien elle est
conduit aux lèvres si nous aurait pas
monkey robes accueillir
[Applaudissements]
et en fait non stop mais qu'en est-il de
kesha on écrit mais c'est pas ça vous a
fait venir tous les deux étages avaient
ils viennent découvrir à l'instant
maintenant pour qu'on les a fait venir
tous les noms mais officiellement je
devrais je dors sans rien mais que je
n'ai pas mais pas tous et qu'est ce qui
nous reste
ah ouais mais le show au mont d'or
carole et les turbines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voyez vous pourriez vous être l'annoncé
je suis un père pour nous de paris vous
la mettez là ne dit rien pendant 45
minutes à bien la courbe d'audience mais
regardez là
[Applaudissements]
le petit nez appel du monde du monde de
la télé mais c'est vrai et le dernier
dernier ouais jean michel lemaire va
vous dire que normalement agents mis les
classes ah ouais ouais
jean-michel meurt c'est youssef
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
la chambre à coucher la chambre à
coucher pour jean michel et son bureau
travaillent là c'est pour les castes et
c'est hugh hefner le patron de playboy
72 on signe de respect pour mon père